is really really really fascinating in
the form of
almost like taking coding agents to the
nth degree is how I when I first saw
this concept is how I framed it in my
mind is what happens when um when you
just let a coding agent go wild and I
think most people's perspective is
nothing much or nothing nothing useful
and I was convinced that that may be
wrong Um, and I think that is really the
topic of today's conversation for
everyone interested. I'm BBOP. I work on
BAML, which is a programming language
for building AI stuff. And my co-host,
uh, I'm Dex. I work on code layer, which
is an IDE for getting more out of coding
agents.
>> If you guys find this kind of stuff fun,
this is the link where we post events
usually up ahead of time, and usually
they have the right link to the live
stream. Uh, [laughter] but I think with
that, we should really get started. I
think we have a really special guest
joining today.
>> I did just send him the link. Um I told
him I would do a quick intro before we
got him on stage anyways. So if you want
to coordinate with him on X or wherever
um and make sure he can get in, I can
start running through kind of what we're
going to talk about today.
>> Do it. Let's get people.
>> Amazing. Okay, so I'm actually going to
start with a demo because that seems to
be pretty fun. Um, I am going to pop
over to my terminal and I have a very
silly little Next.js app. So, if I go to
local S 3000, this is the complete
generic Nex.js starter app. Um, and I
have a couple things in here that I'm
going to go over with you, but I just
want to before I kick this off, I just
want to um kind of create some
specifications for an app that we want
to make. So, uh, Vibob, do you have any
suggestions for an app you'd like to see
us build today?
>> I think we could do something really
complex, but let's do something really
simple so people can we can talk about
the concepts more. Let's make a simple
to like a task manager, like a to-do
list. Very, very basic example, but we
can take it to the end degree and make
it as complicated as we need to.
>> All right, I'm going to do login with
email and magic link. Um, so what users
can add to-dos,
they can group to-dos into lists. They
can share a list of to-dos with other
users.
They can add comments and emoji
reactions to to-dos.
Um, they can mark
to-dos as to
>> doing, done, cancelled.
>> Yeah.
>> And maybe I want to see a conbon board
while I'm at it.
They can view all their to-dos for a
list in a conbon board or view all
to-dos
across all lists in a single board.
Great.
>> Cool.
>> Uh I'm going to kick this
>> simple concept and like took it to the
nth degree because that is more than a
basic to-do app.
>> Yep. Um, so, uh, what we're going to do
is we're gonna NVM deactivate and then
we're going to run this this loop. Um,
I'm not going to tell you what this is
doing because I'm going to pop over to
kind of the, um, let me just make sure
we got our whiteboard up. This is not
it. Okay, this is the whiteboard we'll
be using. I sent you the link. Um, we're
going to learn a technique today called
Ralph Wigum, which was written um by
Jeff Huntley as part of um, a bunch of
research he was doing with coding agents
this year. Um the basic idea here is you
run a coding a in a loop forever. Uh and
you just give it the same prompt over
and over and over again. We'll go into
what that prompt is. Um and you can look
at this and you can say, "Oh, this is
like a very dumb way to use a coding
agent." Uh and Je
>> is a very dumb way to use a text.
>> There he is. What's up, man?
>> I remember dropping in to San Franand
around about July saying just showing
you this thing. It's like this has to be
the dumbest thing.
>> Yeah.
>> Um just to basically research, explore
the limits of what is possible.
>> Um
>> yeah,
>> but it turns out it is
>> you can make it a little bit better.
There are limitations to it. Um
>> yeah, there's so much.
>> I think the main thing that it did for
me when you first uh when I first read
this concept and talked about it with
both of you was really just changed the
paradigm of how I thought about it. So,
we talk about context injuring a lot on
the show. And I think one of the things
that I find myself having to do every
single time and very often is challenge
myself into remembering what can a model
do. Sometimes
>> I'm always I'm always like I get kind of
like um skill capped based on my last
assumption of what the model is doing.
>> And what some of the best AI engineers I
know are the ones that actually like
constantly challenge their own worldview
of what is happening. And I think that
why I like
Why this topic specifically I think was
really useful is because I think it was
the first time when it um challenged my
worldview of what a model can do and it
reframed the perspective of like hey
like there was a time when to build
roller coaster tycoon you had to do bit
magic and make all the stuff work and
like today you can do it way faster and
context engineering is a very very
useful skill set and even today you
still optimize your code but you don't
optimize at the level of bit magic
usually you optimize at the level of
like networking different things have
become bottlenecks and you want you want
to make sure that you constantly evolve
and Ralph Wigum as a concept of running
that while loop and letting it just like
produce an app
I think does that same I don't think
it's there yet like you were saying Jeff
but I think it is
>> it's not all there yet it's not all yet
but but it it warps your brain a little
bit um it's it's got all the I like to
use the term harnesses and models so any
agentic tooling out there like cursor,
wind surf, all these other tools out
there, open code, their harnesses, they
do pretty much nothing. They do pretty
much nothing. It's all the model and how
you use the model.
And
>> so I've got a before we get into this,
Jeff, uh give everyone a quick
background. Who are you? Uh what have
you worked on?
>> Why do you think uh you're awesome? And
and let's let's quickly before you jump
like tell us who you are, what you've
been working on and also like let's work
backwards like talk about cursed and
your experience and how you learned that
and then we'll pop back to the code. I
have a bunch of other examples of other
things you can use Ralph for that we'll
get into actual like code that we'll
ship as part of this episode. But yeah,
give us the intro. How did you find this
and what did you use it to build?
Yeah. So um uh my personal journey with
AI starts ran about December almost a
year ago now. Um I did a very crude
running uh running an agent in a loop
but I was myself attended and then
through myself having to babysit this I
was able to identify like some
abstractions and then I learned a little
bit more about what inferencing is in
that sense and like context engineer in
the early days even before those terms
weren't even defined and I just kept
playing um and I realized if I had long
run one long running chat I was getting
worse and worse outcomes. But if I
clicked new chat and then I and I was
able to encodify that up. So I was a
tech lead over at Campber doing AI dev
tooling. Um moved over this when I saw
you uh Dex. So I was over at SourceCraft
was one of the engineers building AMP.
>> Um and where I am now is not public
knowledge. Um
typical good things.
>> Yeah. Um, so,
um, for me it was always
>> You did something very specific that I I
personally thought was very impressive.
One of your first earliest like mad
crazy AI projects, cursing.
>> Yeah. So, that that was like
it was kind of kind of there's so many
people just saying, "Hey, uh, it's not
good enough yet. I'm only going to be
interested when it makes a programming
language." And I didn't have to pay for
tokens.
I didn't have to pay for tokens. I'm
like, bet.
>> And that's the goal, right? Is like
everybody who's building with AI is
like, yeah, you don't want to just spend
tokens and throw them into the black
hole. But the more
meaning the more you can spend
meaningful tokens on things that
actually make progress, even if it's
incremental or small progress, you want
to spend as many tokens as possible.
This is what we always pitch. It's a
little bit of a meme, but it's like at
the end of the day, that should be your
goal is like how can you spend as many
tokens on meaningful work with as little
human input and effort as possible,
right?
>> Exactly. Um I I've heard stories of
companies capping uh productivity like
like a max dollar spend of like $500 a
month per employee type stuff. And then
none of that stuff makes sense. Um you
you don't want to cap uh uh people like
they're when they're productive um and
you do want to ensure that you you are
getting incremental output. So Kirst was
kind of proving that hey look it you
could make a new programming language.
Now, it's it's pretty much the dumbest
way to do it because it'd be re much
easier to clone the Golang source code
and just use reax and just like relex.
It
>> would have been change all the keywords
and leave all the source code the same.
>> Just change the keywords. There's a
keyword swap, right? So, it was a for me
playing around with the idea of like
what languages work best for LLMs.
So I started in C and I was able to see
that it was uh it was able to do a prep
pasa pretty well. Uh it was going quite
it was making progress but it was going
backwards because there was not what I
described as like back pressure on the
generation. So some sort of type system
etc or like it lms can drive GDB
and you it's able to troubleshoot
itself. you add print f debug logging
but it was just going backwards. So
cursed originally was in C. Um then I
took it over to
>> curs the cursed compiler itself that
like generates like
>> yeah cursed compiler itself originally
it's actually three compilers in the
history there on GitHub.
>> First first was in C.
>> Go ahead.
>> Um it was in C then it went to Rust then
it went to Zigg.
>> Let's get into it. I want to ask I want
to ask a couple quick questions when you
were doing this. So let's to catch
everyone else up. What is the goal of
curs? So one, we wanted to make a new
programming language with the goal of
pushing current models to their limits
and see what is possible. And I think um
I can say it best, making a programming
language is [ __ ] hard. Um I've been
doing a bit you build a real programming
language not as a joke.
>> Um and like it is really hard. And
you're right, AI models do struggle with
this. And this is why I was a really big
skeptic on AI coding in general for a
while because like I was like there's
just certain classes of problems where
they don't work well in but obviously I
feel differently now. Um so I want to
like tell the goal of it. So cursed lang
you write a cursed file. What happens
from like a whiteboard? What happens
next? So you write a cursed file. The
compiler is supposed to do blah fill in
blah.
>> Yeah sure. Um it's essentially uh it has
LLVM back end um okay and it also has
interpreted mode. There's a couple bugs
um that I need to resolve uh to get over
line. Um this thing has been the biggest
test of faith for me. We'll get into
that a little bit later. Um, but the
ultimate goal for me was really to test
the boundaries
of what is possible for research and
understanding how to drive an LLM really
hard. For example,
um there's a there's a f there's a this
uh LLM
um people say, well, it's not in the
training data set. It can't be done.
I was out there to prove that wrong.
Like the fact that it can make a
compiler
>> not that interesting, right? There's a
huge tone of knowledge. It's it fact
that it can make a compiler is not that
interesting to me. What is interesting
is how the heck did it generate all of
the actual programs in the language when
it's not in the training data set.
>> So I've got I think that's a really
interesting thing. We should double
click on that. So the question I have
for you is I think one of the decisions
that you made for cursing in the very
very big uh first uh is that you're not
going to reinvent all the syntax. You're
going to say I want to copy the syntax
of go effectively and I'll change the
keywords to mean something totally
different where it doesn't really matter
to the model and then what I will do is
then I will convert that to an LVM back
end. Do you leverage any of the existing
Go pipelines to do any of that work or
do you go straight from curs to LVM?
curse straight to LLVM.
>> Okay, perfect. So, that's part one. I
think just so people can understand what
that is. What is LVM? A lot of people
may not know. I'll just give a quick
primer. LVM is the premise of like uh
for those of you that don't know how to
describe this in a really good concrete
way.
When you want to write uh
at some point your code has to convert
to a lot of bits and machinery that a
machine operates. You don't want to run
all the assembly instructions yourself.
LVM is just
>> you don't want to roll
>> you don't want to roll for x86 you don't
want to roll for ARM you don't want to
run roll for different CPU architectures
you just want to like a common format
that you can target and that handles uh
the lowering
>> yeah and it also does a lot of the
optimization stuff so you get to take
advantage of all the optimizations and
everything on there a lot of existing
systems used uh LVM uh for a lot of it
if you've ever used client that uses LVM
I'm pretty sure JavaScript also does
that but I might be wrong.
>> Oh sorry that's not what I meant.
>> Remember right it was an Apple invent
clang came from Apple.
>> Yeah.
>> So this entire objective C ecosystem
swift um pretty much everything targets
clang. Clang so targeting LLVM is
normally the compiler's nerdy
destination they want to get to.
>> Yes. So the the the the point here, I
guess, is the idea that like this is
this is not vibe coding your Nex.js
website. This is incredibly complex
systems coding that is probably not as
well represented in the training set.
And I think what was really interesting
to me about this is like Jeeoff, do you
want to walk through kind of like how
you've set things up? show us kind of
like early version of prompt.mmdday,
early versions of the specifications
like what are the inputs to Ralph that
that that allowed you to output a bunch
of code and also like you know hundreds
of markdown files, right? That's the
joke that everyone talks about now is
like Claude just dumping out tons of all
uppercade markdown files.
>> Yeah. So it started with a simple
prompt. The simple prompt is, hey, I
want to make a compiler. Um, but all the
lexical keywords are Gen Z.
So, yeet, vibe, slay, highkey, low key,
that's it. And, um, you see in tools
there's a planning mode.
Um, these planning modes are basically
nothing. There's basically an additional
prompt that uh says do not implement. So
if you want to do planning, all you got
to do is choose a model that's good for
planning. So GPT5 is pretty good for
planning. Gemini is pretty good for
planning. I think I either used
Sonnet or Gemini 25 in the early days
and I specifically prompted do not
implement your goal is to have a
conversation. So the context window is
best just being seen from a consumer
point of view as an array that's
continually appended to with messages.
So I'm having a large conversation
about hey I want to build a compiler.
What could a compiler need? And I'm like
steering it left and right etc. And I'm
not never giving it permission to
implement.
I'm just loading up this array with all
this context.
I have a discussion about different
types of pasa designs. I I I talk about
LVM. I going to use this language. So
I'm loading up this just continually
appending to this array. My both myself
and also the outcomes of actually using
the LLM itself. Um the result of asking
a question appends to that array.
Once I'm satisi satisfied, I tell it to
create out a markdown markdown file
called specs.md. I give it one prompt uh
and that prompt is hey can you uh write
out to a folder specs slash
um one file per topic like for lexical
one is a file grammar is a file
uh yada yada yada yada and I got all
these files and that's that's the
baseline
now
um this part is this is the part that's
really really important
uh one one line bad co one bad line of
code is one line bad line of code
but like uh a bad spec will like one bad
line of spec can result in tens of
thousands or 50 thousands or hundreds of
thousands
worth of bad code output. So when I
first kicked this off, if you roll back
the GitHub history to the bit the GitHub
history to the beginning of time, you'll
come across things like uh I had two two
of the keywords for the programming
language. They had a jeweled meaning cuz
I the specs were wrong. So So when I
kicked it off in the loop unattended,
guess what it got most of the way and
then it tore itself down like it was
brilliant but dumb. It these things
can't think. So this is um I'm just
going to quickly kind of show for
example some of the files that are in
the specifications which is like this is
actually like the grammar of the
language with a bunch of examples right?
>> Yeah.
>> And I have a question here. How much of
this stuff did you read? You were
running this in a pure while loop. So
almost no interruptions on your end.
If I was paying for tokens, I would have
put a lot more care in this. And because
this was meant to be like a Dogecoin or
programming languages,
[laughter] um, I just kicked it off,
um, and just put it on YouTube and like
Twitch and just walked away. And I just
watched it build and tear down build the
Roman Empire and tear down the Ro Roman
Empire. I think it reimplemented the
Lexa
uh, [laughter] probably at least 10
times.
Um, and before I just cuz I'm just
looking at it. Like if you look at the
output of your from your harness, you
can start to notice patterns and
behaviors and you start asking the why
is that happening? It's like, oh, I've
seen it. Why is it going in a loop?
Kill the the while true loop and then
eventually like, oh, you idiot.
So, it's really important to your point,
Dex,
>> is if you if you're doing this serious,
>> spend your time reading the specs
>> before you kick off anything.
>> Yeah,
>> this is the uh
>> Oh, go ahead. One really interesting I
wanted to call out was actually just the
the concept here of uh that I think is
really undervalued when you actually
work with a coding agent versus working
with a human. You said you rewrote this
thing like five times.
>> Yep.
>> When you rewrote this thing like five
times, it's fascinating because like
what you can do is with a no with a
person, you can't just tell someone to
go delete the code and rewrite it again.
There's like feelings involved. This is
a motivator [laughter] feelings.
>> It's it feels different to tell a person
to say, "Hey, rewrite all your code
versus telling an agent, I don't like
that. Restart from zero."
>> In some ways, that's actually a thing
that people should be leveraging more
and more,
>> not absolutely thinking about the old
way of writing code because everything
in coding is almost always incremental.
>> And usually the biggest tax is like,
"Hey, we don't want to rip it out and
redo everything again." It's way way
faster in many scenarios to actually
just rip it out. You you said you redid
it again from like you said see rust and
sick.
>> Yep.
>> You could have never done that in the
old world where like you need a human to
go do that. You'd get so much like um
like like just like stuff you have to
deal with that's just like ah
>> now we have to go. Turns out
>> I have emotional connection with the
specs
>> number. When I was technically back over
at Camber, I remember an engineering
director
>> saying, "Jeff, why did you implement it
in Rust? Rust is not an approved
language here."
>> And I was just sitting there on the Zoom
call. I just deleted the source code.
Just just delete the source code. Just
like, "Yep, all right. See you in 8
hours." So, I put on like Jag and this
is before I was just sitting down
watching like old episodes of Jag and I
and I was just pressing continue
continue. It's like here it goes. It's a
Golang now and it's like 40,000 lines of
code in 8 hours and [laughter] it's like
with full TUI this full TUI. It's the
the equivalence of like the equivalence
of uh Goose Goose with LCP and all this
stuff just
>> I want to start watching TV.
>> I want to start diving a little bit
deeper into some of these concepts. So
you said one of the things that you were
talking about earlier was like which
programming language works better for
AI. Let's talk about that because you
said you tried three for a very
complicated problem. We have chosen Rust
for building a programming language and
I have feelings about AI vibe coding
Rust. Um, and I have feelings about AI
coding C++. I have feelings about AI
putting TypeScript, Python. I want to
hear your perspective. What did you
learn um
about each of the three implementations
that I think helped you understand
better what the model was doing and what
the model is not capable of doing?
So I'd like to uh I see the I visualize
software development as bit of a wheel
in the sense that the top half of the
wheel is the generation phase and then
that's the top half of the wheel and
then eventually that wheel as it turns
is going to hit the road and the road is
basically where you need a bit of
friction to be able to move the car
forward and I call that back pressure.
So with C there were there's no
friction. There's no back pressure like
it's an untyped language
etc. And there's no back pressure.
>> Back pressure. I just want to drill in.
That's that's things like the model
being able to run a unit test suite and
understand if things are working. the
model being able I mean part of the
reason I think that makes programming
languages such a good like example use
case for unattended coding agents is
precisely because you can create this
loop of like it's not a website where
the model has to take a picture of it
with playright and then decide if it
looks good or not. It's like write the
source file. If the compiler can compile
it and the source does what we think it
should do then it works. And so the
model can give itself its own feedback
without having to like have opinions
just by reading or reviewing the code
itself.
>> Is that like kind of what how how would
you expand on that in terms of how you
define and think about back pressure?
>> So let me pull this up.
>> Um we're into an area here where this is
not really vibe coding. It's more like
vibe engineering.
Um so um this is del you're deliberately
putting your engineering hat on. So you
take your your specs which is like your
PD what you want to generate that's the
top half of the wheel. You got your
technical uh pattern library on how like
logging what else have you and that's
like typically language agnostic
typically agnostic. Um, and then you got
the bottom part, the bottom half, and
that's that's where it's your job uh to
put your engineering hat on, run your
unit tests, run the build, program
anything in there like a security
scanning software um that you would
normally do. But the key thing is the
wheel needs to spin fast and the the
bottom half of like the cargo test
clippy that I've got shown here, it
needs to be enough back pressure to stop
the wheel from turning if the code
generation step was bad. if it if it's
any form of hallucination in the output.
Um, and I realized that if I look at it
from the right way and like I'm just
sitting down watching TV,
um, and I'm just doing these things
manually, I could do a while true loop.
I could probably just do a bash loop.
And that's how it came to be. Um,
there's a question in, uh, in the, uh,
in chat and I'll address it, Dave. Yes.
Uh, no one as far as I'm aware of has
actually successfully did it, but I I
started reimplementing OS step in three
easy pieces using Ralph and it got
sufficiently along the way enough where
I was able to boot a VM uh so a virtual
box machine. was able to read the text
console out. From there, I was able to
basically engineer the bottom half of
the loop and I got got all got all the
way like in uh past bootloadader and we
start getting into like
next couple chapters of OS step. Um
these LLMs know what a compiler is
better than I did at the time and they
know what an operating system is at a
implemented level better than I do. So
you can you can lean upon that but you
still need to have your brain on to your
question Bab of like different
languages.
It's the speed of the wheel
that matters like how fast it turns.
[snorts] So if we we look at Rust, Rust
is a strongly typed language
and the good thing about a strongly
typed language is it will reject any bad
like generation. It's very particular.
That's it's things like Haskell is the
same like strongly typed language is
really good. Um because that provides
soundness in the language by default.
If the language doesn't have that
soundness, you need to do more
engineering like you you have to wire
that stuff in. Like if you on Python,
you would have to configure your like
your uh your your pyite like your your
actual type checkers. Um same with
TypeScript on the compiler yada yada
yada you get the idea. Um so but Rust's
compiler is slow.
Uh the Rust compile compilation speed
can be really really slow. So there's a
tradeoff.
um
you want the generation speed to be
sufficiently slowed down but you still
want the generation speed to be fast.
So if you've got a single loop running
then the speed of the generation the
inferencing step and the speed of the
compilation is essentially your velocity
and output unless you concurrency it
have some form of concurrency.
now.
>> So,
>> um, I've done C, I've done Python, I've
done Elixir, I've done Zigg,
I've donenet,
um, I've done Java, I've played with
them all like almost got into like a
like a tier list
>> of what languages LM are good at
writing.
>> Yeah. Um, so and
>> finish your point and then I wanna I
want to jump back into code and like
whiteboarding and kind of talk a little
bit more under the hood about, you know,
how do context windows work and why is
like Ralph such a good strategy based on
the concepts of context engineering.
Does that sound good? Bye Bob. You good?
>> Sounds good. Um, I would like to say
it's how you drive the LLM, which will
segue into context engineering
>> that matters.
>> Um, all the sample applications in Kurs
Kirst is about 15 million lines of code
folks.
Okay. um and all the sample applications
and all the things in there that they
were generated by the LLM and the LLM
was not trained on that data. It was
through the context engineering I was
able to create the right loop where it
was able to generate program for
something it hadn't been programmed on.
>> So you can do some really
>> make one um go ahead.
Yeah, you can do some really uh you can
do some really unhinged things. Um you
can either
work on its inbuilt training data set,
but if it lacks the training data set,
it's how you do the context engine that
matters.
>> So let's take a let's take a deeper dive
into that really fast. But before we go
into that, you mentioned a couple things
about the tra the loop being the most
important part. I think it's really when
I think about it, I think it's about
trade-offs that you want to make in your
engineering cycle. So, let's talk about
the different trade-offs we might want
to make. One is about speed.
>> Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, let's
let's get practical. Sorry, I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna hijack this
conversation. We can keep talking about
theory, but let's do a little bit of
practice and we can work that use that
as a as a platform to do the theory on.
>> Let's show the platform. Let's show the
prompt. MD that you have. I think that's
actually
>> Exactly. We're going to show the prompt
and then I'm going to I'm going to
whiteboard out kind of how we how we
like to talk about this. Um, so we have
prompt MD. Um, it's a very simple
prompt. This is very similar to the one
that I think was the initial one that
Jeff published with the Ralph paper.
Jeff, you can read this prompt and romp.
You can you can roast this prompt, but
>> it's essentially very very short. It's
read the specs, read the code and
source, read the implementation plan,
and implement the single highest
priority feature using up to 50 sub
agents. Now, I'm using Claude with the
default, so it'll only do like five max.
I haven't changed the Envar that lets
you have more sub agents, but I left
this in as a nod to curs. uh ensure all
the tests and linting passes, then
update implementation plan with your
progress, and then commit. And so we can
see this has been working. We have a few
commits going on. Phase one, phase two.
Um I'm going to show you what we're
actually running under the hood as well.
Um and I'm actually going to make a
quick tweak to this. So this is our this
is our our loop. Um, I'm actually going
to run this headless, but basically what
we're doing is I'm running it with
Claude instead of AMP, but we're running
Claude with dangerously skip permissions
and stream the JSON, and we're piping
into this little visualizer. When you
run Claude in headless mode, um, you
basically get this like JSON output. Um,
and so it's going to stream out all this
stuff. We wrote a small little
visualizer that basically makes this a
little bit nicer to look at. Um, but
it's the same. It's just pars. It's all
it's doing is parsing that JSON. So,
we're catting that prompt over and over
again. I'm going to show you when I
started this um it basically
um had no implementation plan file. So,
it just created this based on the specs
and it's been going through and creating
all the CRUD operations. It's created
the allegedly like the database schema.
I believe it shows like um Prisma and
Postgress as the but I I gave it no
guidance on how to do this stuff. Um,
and it's just taking notes and keeping
its own like list of tasks in the plan.
>> Um, and we can go and have a look and
see how it's doing. I actually I saw
that in the M.LE
it had created uh Gmail keys. Um, which
I've actually I added one more piece.
This is an idea of like when might you
want to actually steer this is I wanted
it to use resend because I don't want to
give it my Gmail keys live on the
stream. So, I just added a new feature
and an example should have uh should
have a resend API key. So, it has it
hasn't picked this up yet. Um, but I I
want to get into kind of like what's the
structure of this prompt and like why is
this like, you know, uh Malik and Code
and compiling and all this stuff. Um,
Jeff, you're a Kubernetes guy, right?
>> Yeah. Um, so one of the things that we
like to think about in terms of like
when I think about Ralph is as in terms
of control loops, right? Yep. And so
every component in a lot of like
complicated systems that are able to run
autonomously is they have a very focused
what we call control loop where you have
the desired state of the world, you have
the current state of the world and then
you take one action to progress the
current state towards the desired state
and then you read it again. And you kind
of do this in a loop forever. And if all
the components have the right like
federated responsibilities, then this
becomes a really nice model like mental
model for thinking about your code. Yes.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, but that's one of the
harder things is because everything is
so undeterministic. That's why I use the
image of Ralph in the oven. um that loop
is either underbaked,
perfectly baked or overbaked with later
tendencies or things you never
specified,
>> right? If these two things are equal,
well, the models want to be helpful. And
so even if they're equal, the model will
find something to do because you've
invoked you've invoked the cloud CLI.
It's like, well, it's it's default. It's
heavily trained to do something, right?
And so then it will come up with more
actions and it usually defaults to
changing the desired state of the world
to justify its continued existence and
working. Right?
>> A concrete example is when I was running
a loop, it decided to add some types to
the programming language. I never
specified some types, but you do a 100
loops and it says it's done, it's done,
it's done. on the 105th time and five
times complaining it's done
it hallucinates and says well a
programming language should use some
types and next thing you know that the
way I was driving it was just completely
brainless it would decided to add some
sub some types to the implementation
plan
>> I love it
>> and it's off to the races so it's like
baked underbaked baked or baked with
latent tendencies all these kind of
properties and behaviors are
controllable
but um that's a little bit more abstract
than we can get here. Now,
>> so coming coming to the context window
side of this, essentially like we have a
the most common way to work with AI
models is you have all your system stuff
and then you have your user message. And
the idea is that this will usually get
you to about you know depending on how
many MCPS you have somewhere between
five and 60% of your context window. But
let's assume you're being responsible.
This gets you to like somewhere between
five and 15% of your context window
used. I'd like to see that you got about
176k. Ignore the million etc. It's still
all it's still like 200.
>> So you take 200, you minus 16 for your
harness prompt to minus 16 for your LLM
system prompt. Just the rough numbers.
>> Yeah.
>> And then all of a sudden you got about
176 usable. You add your MCPs in and
that comes out of 176. So now all of a
sudden you're like you've had 50k of
MCPs, you're now down to like 100 120k
usable.
>> Well, and also if you fill like if let's
say you don't have a lot of MCPS, if you
like the most high performance range I
found for the models is like before you
hit this 30 to 40% mark and anything
past there. So, if this is all full of
[ __ ] MCPs, then you're actually doing
all of your work in the like what I call
the dumb zone
>> where there's so much context in terms
of like here's all the things you can do
that it becomes much harder to actually
get it to do something valuable.
>> This is conceptually universal
regardless which LLM that you choose or
which model you choose. This is a
fundamental thing. The less you use, the
better it h it gets. I when I was back
in February, I was noticing
uh like kind of a a degrading like a
degrade the more that I used it.
>> Yep.
>> Um and then that was just through like
kind of like jazz banding kind of with
the LLM like pure observation and lots
of time playing with it.
>> Um nothing scientific but
>> I'll toss a slightly more controversial
opinion. I think that was very very true
a long time ago. I think it's becoming
less true um with every new release that
they put out personally because they
have more they have more training data
for longer context data like it's so
definitely true that longer context
training data is very hard to collect
but now with all these coding agents
running a muk they have really long
continuous sequences of training data
>> that that I think are making the models
better. Yes, they are getting better,
but I've said this every at least twice
a week since April, maybe even earlier,
is like they are getting better, but no
one will disagree even when the models
support 10 million context token windows
like and actually they can do something
with it. No one will deny that you get
better results if you use less because
the attention is spread over less noise,
right?
>> And don't mix the concerns. Don't mix
the concerns. Don't don't just like have
a the way most people use cursor is they
take that window there, they continually
append to it and it's like sweet, it's
all working now. I'm going to make the
website pink. Oh, now I'm going to do
some data SQL migrations and all those
unrelated things are appended in there.
And
>> to be clear, folks, when you
>> this array that gets appended, it gets
appended and sent back each time. It's
stateless. like you just send it back.
You send it back.
>> Um, so when you have unrelated things,
>> it makes
>> no sense. So I'm going to find a
picture.
>> That was one of the the key things was I
realized if I useless drove the context
window with and had one item per task,
good outcomes.
>> Yeah. And this is kind of the idea is
every time you're sending the entire
thing to the LLM, the only thing that
determines whether it is going to pick
the right next step or the wrong next
step is what was already in the context
window. And coding agents are
interesting because you don't actually
write every word of what's in the
context window. You have to kind of
guide it to I mean you could paste in
the contents of all the files that
matter. But the idea is it's slightly
easier to be like, read these four files
and then go do one thing. And then when
the one thing is done, then you're
sending the whole conversation of like,
cool, they said read these files and
then they said do this thing and now
they're saying do this thing. And
there's just like more for the agent to
think through and decide which part of
this conversation is relevant to the
next edit call or the next write call or
the next search call. Yes.
Um, all right. I want to model this a
little bit differently and then I'm
going to go through a couple different
use cases that I love using Ralph for.
Um, and I'd love to hear your thoughts,
Jeff, on which of these you've had
success.
>> Yeah. Let's go to let's actually go to
the next part of Ralph. So, we're told
it to create the specifications.
>> Well, so,
>> uh, the next
>> really really quick, I just kind of want
to like model how like how Ralph works
in terms of a context window. Sure.
>> Is so we have our desired state of the
world, which is, you know, read the
specs.
Um,
right. Read the specs, then read the
source code. That's the current state of
the world. And then our implementation
plan is kind of like the rolling action
plan. And by because we only tell it to
do one thing, we end up with we end up
with using like you're more likely to
stay in the smart zone of the context
window versus the dumb zone.
>> Correct?
>> And then you bomb out. You say just do
one thing and then exit. And so rather
than telling, hey Codeex, keep working
and don't stop working and make sure
don't stop working after nine tasks and
don't stop working after 10 and trying
to prompt it to be able to remember to
keep working. You just say, hey, you
have a really easy job. Stay in the
smart zone, pop one thing off of the
implementation plan list and go do that
and then you're done. And then actually
you can
>> horrendously inefficient.
>> You see the top of the line where it's
decide a decided state of the world, the
user message and the harness, etc. Yeah,
>> what you're doing is you're you're
actually malicking uh and burning a lot
of tokens so it can just do that one
thing. It's it's highly inefficient and
that because I wasn't paying for tokens,
I didn't care. Um but the idea was if I
could deterministically allocate the
array,
>> yes,
>> or the context window
then and I tell it to to do one thing, I
didn't care if uh like to the costs. But
the idea was allocate one thing to the
array to the context window and do one
thing and just burn lots of tokens. Um I
could have forked or clone context
windows and got snazzy and stuff, but
really what I'm doing is just malicking
the the array the same time every loop.
>> So what's interesting here is like what
we have here is desired current and then
implementation plan. And so what that
might let you do is actually cache if
you if you if you tune it just right,
you may actually be able to cache this.
Now I know the claude system message
actually like changes based on the get
dirty state, but like you could
potentially set this up so that you're
constantly forking off of this set and
so you're only updating the current
state of the worldly implementation
plan. This is where context engineering
comes in. I intentionally made a mistake
in this prompt because when I at@mention
this it means it gets pulled in as part
of the user message which means there's
no way we're going to be able to cache
any of that because it's going to read
the implementation plan as part of the
user message and so none of the rest of
this can be cached
>> anyways that's it's totally a tangent
but that does that match your
understanding?
>> Yep.
Um
>> um
>> what we've done what we got drawn out
here is we told it go immediately to the
implementation plan
>> um but we haven't told how the
implementation plan came to be.
>> So the second train of thought there was
>> okay I've got my specs
I've generated them in the context
window of research planning and then I
gave it permission to write markdown
then I've thrown away that array.
The next step is I would run lots of
loops.
Um, I was using Gemini for its large
context window when I first started,
probably around about Juneish.
>> And maybe it was Marchish, Junish,
Marchish. And um, essentially what I
said was
uh,
>> so you would be giving it
>> Sorry.
Yeah,
>> study the specs to understand what needs
to be implemented.
Then uh what I want you to do is look at
the source code directory and set the
two. Tell me what's not implemented.
That's the high level theory.
>> Yeah,
>> set the two and
run that many times. Lots of times. Lots
lots of times. and then tell it to write
an implementation plan.
>> So when you run it lots of times like
are you running it in a single context
window and it's going and doing all the
reading or is it like is there what's
the exhaust from each run of this loop?
>> I try to blow the context window up in
this stage.
>> You try to have as much context as
possible. load as much a big the big so
this is back when Gemini was
>> so you're literally doing a million and
then Claude was like tiny like Claude
was tiny um but the idea was
>> get it to execute RIP GP lots of times
and get like get like no fs no fs
because
>> when it's searching the source code
versus specifications what it's doing is
it's executing a tool and that tool is
rip grip and rip RIP powers the source
code intelligence for all the coding
harnesses out there. Like Ripcript runs
the world, but the input to the function
of what it searches for the search query
into RipG is nondeterministic.
It's generative
>> generative based on what it's seen so
far.
>> It's generative input to a to a
deterministic
uh tool. So I ran it lots of times.
>> So you did this all in one context
window over and over and over again. Let
it do something
>> over and over and over again.
>> Run and over. And then at the very end,
you say, "Write the implementation
plan."
>> Pretty much like I'd either do it by
hand or I'd run it in a bash loop and
blow the stack.
>> Okay.
>> From a very tangible perspective, when
should someone do this? Like this Ralph
Wiggum technique of where you run this
in a while loop, you let it rip.
pull up some of the examples that we
have and I'd love to get Jeff your
thoughts on this. Um, and then we'll
come back at the
>> Did you repeat yourself? Starling
dropped out
>> next.js server.
>> Uh, we're going to look at some other
examples.
>> Yeah. Of what of what what Ralph can do
not not just for the not not just for
building a new programming language from
scratch, but um
>> there's forward modes, there's research
modes, and there's reverse modes. So
this is what I have here as a reverse
mode. So this is our your job is to
build the specifications for we have a
process that's written in Golang and we
want to rewrite it in Typescript and so
I've written kind of the same style of
prompt to build out specifications
from so it's like read the code
familiarize yourself with what's in the
specs but now this is the desired state
of the world and this is the current
state of the world because our output is
specifications.
Does that sound right?
>> Yep. So, I've ran Ralph in reverse
>> and I've cloned things that I went I
heard that like commercial open source
companies like crazy stuff crazy crazy
stuff just ran it in full reverse and
then
um due to a pecuriality in Australian
copyright law because it was kind of
like no effort involved. It was computer
doing it. It's actually legal.
So you could take a proprietary code
base,
>> take it up to your white label
specifications,
>> throw away the tainted IP and then Ralph
run Ralph forwards.
>> So let me u let me try and reframe this
question really fast. For example, we
run everything BAML's run purely in
Rust. Let's say I decided tomorrow that
I want to migrate our 300,000 lines of
Rust code as a compiler to Zig.
>> Bro, did you did you know what I was
doing on this episode? This is literally
my one of my examples.
>> That's so funny. But um I not know that.
But I have a question. Give me your
overunder on how well you think that
would work in terms of the most
important part being opaque reliability
to a user. How how much would you trust
it? Because the hardest part about the
system is like
>> the testing coverage is very hard at the
end of a real code base. So in this
scenario, I bet we could get a prototype
that gets pretty close. But how how
close to current parody would we
actually get?
The way I look at Ralph is kind of like
a a principal software engineer who
wants to
uh get something done
without having to like sit down for
endless meetings. Like the specs is your
kind of the PRD, the working code
prototype. Um, you can use it to get
essentially an army of interns to just
get a concept in your idea out really
fast.
Um, conceptual prototype without like
enough if you have an idea that you
could scaffold a team around you pretty
much instantly,
right? And there's no nothing precious
about the source code. So that's that's
the level of maturity that I I think at
now. I've had successes in essentially
oneshotting things. It it it you got to
really think about the unit the concrete
unit of domain. So I like when I was
over at source graph I there was a
really good um mermaid library in Golang
and it had really good property based
tests
and because of those really good
property based tests I was able to go oh
I can use those property based tests as
input data to drive the new generation
to reject if the new generation is bad.
So it was like take this Golang like
mermaid diagram drawer and make it in
Typescript and then we're able to just
essentially transpile and use the old
test data to drive the loop or the new
one
>> and you didn't even have to imple you
didn't even need to have to implement
the testing feedback back pressure loop.
You just had to have it designed. You
had to know what the properties you
wanted to test. This is the engineering
engineering not coding.
>> The the people who are really really
good at this like agentic engineering
they'll spend three days designing the
back pressure harness. They won't even
implement it. They'll just design the
answer to the question how will the
model know that it's working and then
they'll spend three days on that and
then they'll just hand it to the model
and let it cook for 48 hours and they'll
come back to 50,000 lines of working
code.
So I have a question about this because
I think this premise that you're saying
is very similar to why the Rust language
exists. Like Rust exists like why does
code in Rust mostly just work? I mean
part of it's just syntax. My personal
opinion is that because like testing is
one of the few things that is built into
Rust as a part of the core language not
as a part of like an afterthought. Like
in Python you have to import piest to do
it. In Typescript to import Jest like
test is just a syntax.
>> For someone that has never seen Rust
code I'll just show you guys really fast
what I mean. And I have a the reason I'm
asking this is because I actually do
have a question about this
which is um like
>> I describe this as the soundness of the
language
>> like right over here like I don't know
about that but like I think R is
beautiful but I know many people that
probably would like disagree like you
basically mark a test as a test thing
and now you can one you get really nice
hooks to run this and this is like a CLI
command run
you can just write test anywhere in the
file it doesn't need a file any just
become a test. So if I for example let's
say this is sorry this is very
complicated code. I'll just let's say I
wanted to write a test for this
function. I could literally just write
really quickly cfg test. Boom. I now
have a test for this function.
Uh and this will test this function for
me and do something with it if I wanted
to. And the fact that I can just write a
test really quickly means that whenever
I write Rust code, I will basically
never um how do I how do I describe it?
I'll basically never ever break my code
because the minute I get a bug, I just
add this test into here and now my code
is just magically tested from here on
out.
>> And the fact that the language does this
makes that the loop is really good. But
what the question I have for you guys is
what I run into is even if I write the
test in theory this Ralph Wiggum
technique should work with any coding
agent. It it shouldn't really require
the Ralph Wigum technique. I should be
able to do this in cloud code in codeex
and in any scenario. What is the alpha
that I'm getting specifically with the
Ralph Wigum technique and what is what
help me distill that into like a one-s
sentence um difference between just
running Claude code from both of you
independently. I'd love to hear that
>> the
it's distilled down to I realize the
LLMs understand what a compiler is
better than most university students or
people who are many years past like out
of university unless that's their
professional job. So you can lean upon
that training data set and it can make
decisions
statistically make decisions of what the
next logical order of things that should
implement. So if we're not talking about
compilers quickly, I've had it run
through an implementation plan for
um an implementation plan and it's done
logging first. Like it's got 20 items to
do. does logging first and then I tell
it it should have telemetry and it does
the telemetry next and then it's uh uh
tenant awareness because I'm doing
multi-tenant applications. So next thing
you know it creates the uh the tenant uh
middleware and none of this the the key
and it it does that and then from that
point forward it it builds continually
on it because it's statistically making
better decisions what to what to
implement than most engineers do or like
even best matching what I would do. It's
it's about the probably the simplest way
of looking at this is we got into our
profession because we loved controlling
computers. It is so good to like the
control aspect. I get to control the
computer.
The people who really get it Dex and
I'll hand over to you is I feel they've
surrendered the control but not their
thinking.
They've they've they they've they've
they've learned to understand that
statistically it can create and decide
what the next step is
as good as what you would do at times.
And at times it's most of the time it's
scary how good it's able to make the the
next step or decision.
>> But is that different than just letting
it rip in cloud code? That's I think
that's what I'm trying to like from a
practical standpoint. I think most
people that are watching and listening
what they do is they use cloud code,
they use codec, they use cursor
uh and like what you guys are doing is
slightly different technique. You're
literally running a prompt and it's
still running through cloud code but
there's a slightly different harness
that you're using to run cloud code is
the way that I describe it.
>> So what is that advantage?
>> So let me yeah let me let me give my
take here. Um because Jeff made some
good points about like hey there's a lot
in the training data set that if you
just kind of like let it figure itself
out you will get good answers to I think
for me the challenge with and I think of
like model inner harness outer harness
right so you have the inner harness
which is something like claude code or
codeex or the CLI and then you have
things like that I would describe as
your outer harness and I've used two
different outer harnesses quite often
one of them is the research plan
implement workflow that works really
well for brownfield code bases and lets
you get like a vertical slice of
relevant context in a really old
codebase so you can make a valid
implementation plan and the review of a
human in the loop like that's our outer
harness. The other outer harness is this
thing like the biggest problem with
these coding agents that requires the
human to be in the loop is like people
say oh cloud code it'll work for a
minute and then I'll have to come give
it the next thing and the next thing and
the next and even if I prompted we saw
some someone from the AI the works
community was giving a talk um at the
unconference and he basically showed us
his prompt and it was like do not stop
after one step do not stop after two
steps do not he literally his whole
prompt was literally just like trying to
convince the model to keep working but
the problem is
>> it doesn't work the models get anxiety
model, it will terminate early.
>> Yeah. And so there's two there's two
pieces of this like one of them is like
how do you get a model to work for
longer than uh it wants to is you
actually have it only you tell it to
work for only a short time and you do
that over and over again. And then the
other side is like how do you do context
engineering? How do you guarantee as
much work as possible? As you say Jay
like Jeff like the more context you use
the worse results you'll get. How do you
make sure that you're doing most of the
work in the smart zone as we call it?
And so how like this allows you if you
can set your specs and allocate them
properly of like exactly how much budget
you know I mean you were the first
person to explain this to me Jeff was
like okay you want to budget about 7% of
your context window for specs 7% for
finding the state of the world you know
3% for actually reading the cont the
implementation plan and then you budget
your you know 10 to 15% for your like
base message and MCPS and all this crap
y and that way you know that like
because it's not just writing the files
it's like 10% 20% of your context window
if that's all you have right if this is
10% for doing the work you need to be
able to do the number of edits you need
you need to be able to run the test you
need to be able to fix the test you need
to be able to update the plan with your
status and you need to be able to commit
like two file edits is enough that like
you're going to fill up 10% of your
context window with everything else and
so this is the other part is like long
horizon by just constantly looping it
through and restarting but also better
results because you're designing it to
only do the smallest possible chunk of
work at a time.
>> Yeah, the bash loop is the most abstract
thing. I was doing this all by hand in
cursor back
like
>> check off the box
>> just absolutely driving it like
>> text
>> just so people get an idea of what we're
talking about the command line tool of
like the what do you just cat it so
people know what we mean by the bash
loop
>> yeah we'll have another look
>> so it's actually
>> there's no silver bullet here
>> there's no silver bullet here. It's it's
how you think and approach the problem
domain. It's not a tool. It's not a
workflow.
Um you could
the bash loop was
nice because I started to see common
failure domains
and then I was able to update the bash
loop to do a git reset hard or like
reset the agent or all these other
things. It allowed me to start thinking
abstractly.
>> So the biggest difference in the hot
seat
>> I'm going to try and summarize what I
took away as the takeaway from this
perspective. If you go back whenever you
show that text.
>> Yeah.
>> The biggest difference between running
quad code or codeex or something else
here versus running the walkwigum loop
from what I see is this ability to go
ahead and when I pull this up is this
ability to say that for extremely
extremely hard tasks what I need to
worry about at all times is the model
will not continue them. And I think I
have personally experienced that and a
lot of people have experienced that.
What I do is because I'm usually working
with Claude or Codeex, it hasn't really
been a problem because I just let it
come. But it's definitely a problem that
if I go to bed and I definitely want
Claw to keep continuing reaching to some
good horizon by the end of the by the
end, then I definitely need to provide
that in some better mechanism.
So in that scenario, what I can do is I
can either prop it and tell the model to
keep going until it's actually done and
hope that it does that or I can force it
to go do this. And the only way I can
really force it to do this is basically
continuously run the process.
>> Like I deterministic again, Claude.
>> Yeah.
>> Like basically add determinism to
running forever.
>> Like for and what I
>> now when I run into this, can you go
back?
>> Uh yeah. Yeah. And then I'll I have a
picture. Yeah.
>> Yeah. And then when you run into this,
the fundamental tradeoff that you end up
here is some tasks do indeed need long
context horizon. And in those tasks,
this loop will not work well because if
you need a long context horizon like
you're you've design the system and I'm
not saying there's you can't modify this
loop to make it run better for those
tasks. But as stated here, this task
will probably suffer because the
implementation plan just may not contain
enough details. And
>> this is when I'd see it
>> to be able to do something.
>> When I see it like hill climbing towards
a destination, it's just not getting
there. Like it's keep resetting hard too
many times.
>> Um this is where you know I do haven't
got here yet. I would throw away the
implementation plan continually because
it was so easy to regenerate the
implement and you start again.
Then you just kick it off and you go
down to the pub and drink a beer.
>> Exactly. So, it's not saying that it
doesn't work. It's just that you
interrupt it. You interact with it in a
different way.
>> Oh, absolutely. This is
>> like It's not like
>> It's kind of like a If you're a really
good M2, like a manager 2, that's kind
of what you do. You're not really going
to go and interrupt. You don't want
stand up bigs from your teams, but you
do need a way to stop a team from going
down the totally wrong direction if
they've been at it for a while.
>> I would. And I think this is kind of the
The reason I had it streaming, V, is so
I I could just rewind to a point in time
and skip through and I was monitoring it
as if I was an engineering manager
getting my daily status updates or my
Jurro board. Like it was a second
monitor that was available on my phone.
I was using YouTube to stream to my
phone with VCR record. And I was going
through reviewing all that work and the
amount of times it's failed
>> and it's failed because of uh the idiot
in front of the computer, me, I gave it
the wrong input data, the wrong
implementation plan, the wrong specs or
I underspecified what the objective is
and it gets that behavior exactly you
described.
>> We've got one really important question
that keeps coming up. How does it stop?
>> Uh and I know we talked about this
briefly. The answer is it stops in
general. You've deterministically said
it should not stop. It stops when you
hit control C. That is it.
>> This is why you do a commit after every
loop when you get a success a successful
compilation. So
>> it's like model training, right? It's
like you overtrain the model and then
you re you roll back to the actual good
version, right?
>> Yeah. The other part that we didn't get
into was uh
a perspective of how when in that loop
is h how you drove the context window,
how you drive the context window. I
realized you could register
uh new context windows
in as tools in an existing context
window. We call them sub aents. now. And
what that meant was I could spawn a
green thread like a new process green
thread and anything that was a minty
allocation like cargo test and maybe
that that maybe that uses 200k of
tokens. I don't want 200k of tokens
appended to the main inferencing loop. I
want garbage collection. I went green
threads with garbage collection. I went
from mal malicking manually with C
memory with C all the way into the JVM
era. I wanted automatic garbage
collection. That's the way I was looking
at it. I wanted I was running a
operating system process as a single
process. Everyone's talking about agent
agent like microservices type stuff. Um
I I don't think it's a thing right now.
But what what I was focusing on is
keeping it simple. And the idea was how
do I keep one process running forever?
That loop running forever. How do I keep
it running forever? And the key was
don't allocate to it. And the way to not
allocate to it is to spawn a green
thread,
>> JVM
like vinking and garbage collect. So the
idea is all you care about is the Unix
return code on cargo test
>> will and
>> we're running a little bit long today.
>> You summarize back to make decisions.
>> I'm going to show one more thing on the
how does it exit and then I'm going to
hand it to you viob.
>> Yeah,
>> we did this
>> uh we did this in a hackathon and we
used it to port a bunch of repos from
Python to Typescript and things like
this. Uh, one of the agents figured out
it was running in an infinite loop and
it figured out how to send a kill signal
to its own process and stop itself. It
like freaked out an existential crisis
and like offed itself. But that's that's
one option of how it finishes is if if
the prompt is in a certain way, it will
figure that out.
>> Um, I have a couple things. We started a
demo at the beginning of this call where
we were like, we ran the raw loop for
the to-do loop. Let's see it. We built a
to-do app. Do you can you share a quick
description of what the initial to-do
app was speced out to be
>> and then I want to show off what we have
now and we'll start with purely the
demo.
So yeah, so here's the spec. You know,
to-dos application login with email and
magic link. Users can add to-dos. They
can group to-dos into lists. Um they can
share a list of to-dos with other users.
They can add comments and emoji
reactions. They can mark. And then I
added in the middle of this I added a
one new instruction. So let's go let's
go have a look at it. Um
>> and it's an X.js app. So we just go look
at it. Cool. Magic links.
>> Yep.
>> Human layer.dev. We'll send a link
there. I'm going to shut resend API key
manually while you
>> I set that in the environment.
>> Agent did not do that. Yes.
>> No. Yeah, I didn't want to wait for it
to do that.
>> Totally valid.
>> Um
let's see. Post offline.
>> Let's see what the app did.
>> So, I'm trying
>> while we're running this demo. people
definitely uh we'll take questions now
for the next five or 10 minutes if
people have them and then we'll go um
we'll try and like just like I said show
the real code of what ended up
concluding at the end of this content
>> cuz like while we were talking a lot
about this I think the best thing about
this episode is we actually don't
there's not much to code and show like
we really just run a while loop with a
very simple prompt in cloud code and let
it rip and I think a lot of this why we
talk so much about theory is because
like
>> honestly that's what's useful in like
understanding why this stuff works
because we'll run this code and we'll
see what happens.
>> So, I didn't get the email yet. Um, so
I'm just going to grab happened to log
out the magic link.
Yeah. So this is what exactly why we
spend so much time in theory because
it's not I see so many pro people going
look at my perfect prompt the like buy
my course of the perfect prompt or the
perfect sub aent persona and all the
rest like it it it it's all about like
engineering is first principles thinking
here um and I'm looking for someone to
come up with something better than a
while true bash loop. Whatever comes
next is going to be really great. Like
how do you solve the halting problem?
Like how do you like
decide when it's going to terminate?
I've seen self- termination. Dex has
seen self- termination. I've seen
underbaking. I've seen perfectly baked
and you just do get reset. This is where
you put your judgment in. And I've seen
overbaked when it's it's added features
because I was silly and I didn't look at
the specifications or was hallucinated
and just on the implementation plan
decide to add something more.
>> Yeah. Like running like
>> think about it yourself as like an
engineer. If someone gives you a
checklist of all the features you want
running and then they're all checked off
and they're like they just give it to
you of like build stuff, you will build
stuff because that is what
>> it just builds stuff. It it's it's kind
of like the Fantasia mop,
>> like the scary uh pdoom
a fantasia mop when I was first coming
across it cuz I realized
>> it just keeps working.
>> This is enough.
>> It just keeps working. This is enough to
to get software I don't know 70% done,
80% done. like the prototype that
normally got off like all this
offshoring that people normally did for
6 months or two years and they they
dropped 100 grand for like a a little
pock like I just don't see the place in
the market for it anymore because a
competent engineer can just run the loop
and and they get the results back in in
in a couple days.
>> I I will tell you one counter-argument
for why I disagree with that though.
Honestly, when I want to when I hire
someone or when I when I ask some
software to solve my problem, I often
most of the time just want the problem
solved for me. And even if I could do it
myself, it's just not as interesting as
just having the problem be solved for
me.
>> Yeah.
>> And I think so like even if even if it's
possible for me to go technically write
the code to go do it, it's still highly
useful for me to hire someone else that
can just go take care of that problem
and spend their time thinking about it.
Because like for example right now
Dexter is working on communicating with
the model to make this work. Could I be
[laughter] doing that 100%. Like I could
go do that but it's definitely useful
for someone else to be doing that and me
not spending my time on there. So like
when people talk about these incredibly
small teams doing everything. I think
one person can definitely do more than
they used to be able to do. But
definitely five people all doing more
than what one person individually used
to do will do more than what five people
used to do before as well. And some
problems, you're right, don't need five
people of work. But some problem, most
problems that are interesting, I think
do need usually at least two people's
worth of work.
>> There's building upon that, there's
there's failure domains, liability, and
warranty domains of business. Like I I I
cloned um uh San Fran um uh PKI startup
um just just run Ralph in reverse to
specifications and ran it forward.
see if it could
>> Did you pull their docs?
>> I put so some of the source code wasn't
available cuz it's enterprise.
>> Sure.
>> So I used their public facing
documentation as additional context to
reverse engineer to get the
specifications cuz the a lot of the
source code wasn't available and it was
able to generate it really well. But
let's be clear, we're talking about PKI
here, folks. Like that's a perfect
example. Like just because you can do it
doesn't mean you're going to do it. but
you're not going to run your business on
it. Um, you it's nice knowing that
there's a a company that I can pay money
to and they're specialized specialist in
this domain.
Uh Dave, your question running in
reverse is literally you take an
existing piece of intellectual property,
whether that be proprietary software or
proprietary documentation
and you essentially do a clean room. You
take it up to specific, you take the
proprietary code, you create uh
specifications
>> in autonomous way
>> and then you throw away the tainted
intellectual property.
>> Um, you need to speak with lawyers
because it could be argued under US law
that it's not a true clean room.
>> Um, I've
>> had some discussions and then you still
drive forwards to implement it.
Both of you have tried this for quite a
few different programs. And before we
close this out, I have a couple
questions that I want to ask you guys.
>> One, how many of your programs got to
past 80% correctness? Like are actually
good and like reliable when you did this
loop?
>> I think it's almost always you can get
to 90 or 95%. There's almost always a
little bit of steering and polishing.
Yeah. Jeff, what do you think?
Uh it I I
think software outsourcing is cooked.
Um like
>> you can get into the high 70s 80s. Like
there's going to be holes.
Um you don't trust the output. When it
says it's done, it's not really done.
Like reviewing code is one of the
hardest things now. um because the
velocity is so fast, it's it comes at
you faster than you can mentally adjust
and then you put a team factor into it.
It's really weird, folks. But
um if I needed to generatively figure
out the shape of it, like why wouldn't
you not take a spec and then implement
it in Zigg and then implement it in Rust
and implement it in Python and then like
go down to the pub, go for lunch, come
back and go, this is what it could kind
of look like. like really lean into the
generative aspects
um which allows you to capitalize on
things that would
there used to be a higher level
emotional connection to me with code.
>> It it doesn't exist anymore. Code is
disposable to me now. Ideas are not.
>> And the other thing is
um
it just feels like code's more
disposable now. It's more throwaway.
It's more like it's more about
um it's idea to execution immediately.
Idea execution, execution, execution,
execution. It's all about the idea. And
that's what's changed. Like it's just
this huge dopamine hit of getting
outcomes. It's crazy. But it's nowhere I
wouldn't call it engineering.
Engineering has li professional
liability to it. If you build a bridge
and the build bridge collapses, then you
should lose your license, should be
sued. Um kind of out of time, but I
think software engineering should have
professional liability to it. Um just
because AI generated it does not mean
>> that I mean
>> that like your brain you need to take
accountability for it.
>> The model will generate 70% done really
fast, really well in a generative way.
>> You can't hang up a shelf and then blame
the drill. Like it's your job to make
sure it's safe.
is um cool. I think with that we should
uh I think this episode has been really
fun. Uh I think that's if Have we got
the website working? Otherwise, we'll
post it later if it works.
>> I'll push all the code when it's done.
It's it's still churning. I think an
hour to bake is not enough time for a
app with that many features. And I was
using Opus. I think we used it would
have gone a little bit faster. I want to
share one more thing that I really love.
Uh thank you so much, Jeff. Uh I'm going
to share my screen one more time. It's a
little give give us all a little pat on
the back here. Um, let's have a look and
we'll we'll end on this one. Uh,
this is the most interesting show on
YouTube. Thank you, Jeff, for joining us
and making it even more interesting than
it is in in general. This was a blast.
Uh, [laughter]
>> until we next catch up in San Fran.
>> Um, we'll get there. And then funny
enough, uh Dash and I for the first time
are actually a room apart uh while we're
doing this thing. We just sadly didn't
have a webcam set up to go do it on the
same computer. Um but for everyone else
that's tuning in, uh this AI that works.
We try and show real working pipelines.
Um we will push the code and all the
markdown files and everything that
Dexter is doing here in the repo. So
you'll get it as per usual. Uh next
week's episode is going to go back to
some interesting context endurance stuff
and how to build a stick pipelines. I
think that'll be interesting and fun.
Uh, come join, sign up, and then we'll
see you guys soon.
>> Bye everyone.
>> Thanks everybody.